an indian jewelry brand has pulled an
advertisement featuring an
interfaith family after a massive
backlash on social media
the advertisement shows a muslim
mother-in-law organizing a baby shower
for her hindu daughter-in-law opponents
to the advertisement
accused the brand of promoting so-called
love
jihad it is a term used by right-wing
hindu groups in india
who believe there is a conspiracy to
convert hindu women to islam
through marriage a twitter user tweeted
this video of the advertisement
before it was pulled
[Music]
[Music]
now the advertisement triggered sharp
responses on twitter
like from this user who asked the
company if it was promoting love jihad
i dare you to do an ad of muslim
daughter-in-law with hindu family
the user went on to say famous bollywood
actress kangana ranaut tweeted that
as hindus we need to be absolutely
conscious of what these
creative terrorists are injecting into
our subconscious
saying further it was the only way to
save our civilization
her colleague actress swarab husker
lamented the withdrawal of the
advertisement by the company
accusing it of a sad lack of spine and
conviction
numerous women and men get death threats
on social media on a daily basis
they stand up to it she said an indian
politician and author shashi tharoor
tweeted
if hindu muslim ekatvam asks them so
much
why don't they boycott the longest
surviving symbol of hindu muslim unity
in the world
india ekatvam is hindi for unity and was
the name of the jewelry line from the
company
and dw correspondent marina choudhary is
on the story for us she joins me now
from delhi
manira why so much outrage over a simple
advertisement
well this is a question that many are
asking why such an outrage over this act
the ad essentially shows a pregnant
hindu woman being escorted
to a hindu style baby shah ceremony by
her muslim mother-in-law which
essentially indicates that the
the woman is married into a muslim
family the tagline of the brand also
under the video suggested that they
wanted to celebrate what they called
the confluence between two different
religions their cultures and traditions
but there's been a massive backlash to
this and critics
attribute this outrage to what they say
is a deep-seated intolerance towards
anything which promotes interfaith
harmony
over the past few years but the
overarching idea
is that any content or any agenda which
talks which is liberal or secular and
talks about
harmony is basically done at the expense
of the sentiments of the hindus which
form the majority of the country
and people who are against this ad who
have been trending boycott
tanishq which is the brand name on
social media saying that this ad
glorifies
what they call love jihad what is this
term love jihad it keeps coming up in
some of the tweets that we have also
shown to our viewers it is there across
social media what exactly is it what is
its
genesis
love jihad basically is understood to be
a hindu fundamentalist conspiracy theory
in which
which alleges that muslim men are
engaged into this conspiracy of
converting hindu women to islam
by marrying them so certain cases in the
past over many years have been picked up
by sometimes fringe elements of local
political parties or even media
to portray the mass cases of love jihad
but they have been probes
uh into this case as well in which
interfaith marriages have been probed
and
agencies have found absolutely no
evidence of love jihad
in which hindu women are being
understood to be being maltreated or
suffer in these marriages but from
everything that you're saying manira it
sounds like there is a religious divide
in india how deep is it
well the hindu muslim divide and the
tensions which follow are nothing new to
india we have seen these issues spring
up over the past many years
at different times in different ways but
critics say that this deep-seated
intolerance towards anything which
promotes
the hindu muslim harmony has faced a lot
of opposition especially under the
current ruling party
which even though the ruling
establishment the main leadership line
has never said so in so many words but
there has been an
understanding that the ruling party
plans more towards the majoritarian view
of the country
and critics say that this idea of
intolerance has been played up by
playing on the sense of hindus feeling
the injustice
as they feel that their interests have
played a second fiddle to those of
muslims especially under the previous
governments
so then does that mean that this is the
end of this particular controversy in
relation to this advertisement
it does look like because the brand has
taken down the advertisement they have
even published a statement that why they
had to take down the advertisements
and also there have been news reports of
the shops of this particular particular
brand being attacked in different parts
of the country
so clearly the social media outrage
which followed
this advertisement over the past couple
of days did push the brand to take this
major step
of actually pulling down the
advertisement and sharing the statement
regarding that
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us manira
chaudhary from delhi